et nous ça vous avez que gérer un
vestiaire chercheur associé à la
fondation d'études pour le moyen-orient
bonjour merci d'être avec nous l'armée
syrienne continue ou continue donc de
progresser dans la province a dit lee
qu'est ce qui se joue dans cette région
du nord-ouest de la syrie en ce moment
une grande partie de bras de fer qui a
commencé depuis le bras de février 2011
à savoir depuis l'évolution du printemps
arabe qui s'est aussi déplacé vers la
syrie et donc si on regarde la carte
n'est ce pas la syrie et la turquie rond
frontière commune
donc là il ya une différence entre la
position russe équipe qui a des
positions en syrie lié à l'histoire
c'est à dire qu'il ya eu un traité
d'amitié soviéto syrien en 1970 qui a
donné à la russie union soviétique
d'alors des points d'appui militaire à
tartous et lattaquié
donc ça c'est l'histoire mais d'un point
de vue géographique la turquie est donc
présente juste à la frontière syrienne
et si on se réfère à un peu la
philosophie de la géopolitique un lien
chercheurs anglais qui s'appelle david
cossin des caddies la géographie de
mines l'histoire dont vous voyez-vous là
on est dans des confrontations qui ont
des racines très très puissante et si on
se reporte à l'intervention aux russes
de septembre 2015
deux mois après il ya un sukhoï 24
russes qui étaient abattus
souvenons nous par les forces armées
aériennes turques
parce que l'avion avait franchi un tant
soit peu la frontière mais c'était une
revanche parce que la turquie avait
demandé à la russie à l'époque de ne pas
bombarder la partie nord ouest de la
syrie
parce que là il ya une population
turcophone
et c'est là le grand enjeu parce que
tout ce qui se passe actuellement est au
sud
alors que tout au nord d'idleb là il ya
les dix points d'appui turc et il y a
donc la population turcophone avec des
positions rebelles anti régime de bachar
al assad
l'armée syrienne a donc repris hier la
ville de saraqeb une ville que l'on dit
stratégiques pour quelle raison elle est
pratiquement sur la route entre damas et
alep
donc voilà les grandes capitales
économiques syrienne donc c'est
important effectivement de pouvoir
pratiquer cet axe routier
donc voilà la raison essentielle d'une
région de communication stratégique et
économique entre la capitale économique
et la capitale politique elle dans cette
offensive l'armée syrienne met en avant
son combat contre les djihadistes et
terroriste est ce qu ils sont affaiblis
aujourd'hui de plus en plus dans la
série en syrie je crois que les rebelles
syriens effectivement sont affaiblis
parce que le temps a fait son effet son
usure n'est ce pas fait son oeuvre à
ange évoqué le début des combats en
février 2011
donc on est à 9 ans de guerre et 9 ans
pour une armée qui est confronté donc de
rebelles qui confrontés à la fois à
l'armée du pays plus aux forces russes a
même s'il ya et en plus des forces
iraniennes
donc vous avez forcément des difficultés
logistiques des difficultés de
recrutement des difficultés financières
vous l'avez évoqué ce bras de fer entre
damas et ankara entre la syrie et la tir
nature qu'il est à des considérations
géographiques historiques haussier est
ce que vous allez le sentiment que ce
bras de fer peut dégénérer en conflit
ouvert
comment est ce que vous voyez
l'évolution de la situation non je pense
qu'on restera dans le gris parce qu'il
ya trop d'intervenants pour que le
conflit puisse s'élargir il à lire on
est présent à nous avez la russie qui
est présente vous avez donc la lyre et
cyriac ils sont chez eux et puis vous
avez la présence qui ont donc à chacun
des jeux et des contre eux je regarde
et le silence russe devant les
bombardements israéliens sur les forces
iraniennes en syrie la russie ne
souhaite pas que l'iran se maintiennent
parce que historiquement l'iran n'était
pas présente en syrie donc quand israël
bombarde bien les russes laissent à peu
près faire mais c'est pas parce que ça
fait partie de cette dualité de
comportement la russie a besoin de
l'iran pour combattre les rebelles et
maintenir bachar el assad au pouvoir
mais dans un deuxième temps il ne
souhaite pas que les iraniens à ce
présent seuls ou en sont les discussions
pour un cessez-le-feu en syrie vous
évoquiez ces acteurs majeurs que sont
les rangs la russie où est-ce qu'on en
ait des négociations
vous avez vu tout à l'heure dans votre
avant propos qu'il y avait aussi un
arbois un envoyé de l'onu nous partons
donc tout le monde essaye de maintenir
des contacts et des négociations à six
une négociation échoue à quelques
semaines après une autre commence
on va être dans ce cycle de stop and go
si je puis dire pendant un certains
nombre de trimestre peut-être d'année
car ce conflit est loin d'être terminé
à cause de la présence turque en syrie à
cause de l'existence d'une population
turcophone en ciel
merci pour votre analyse j'ai un respect
je rappelle que vous êtes chercheur
associé à la fondation d'études pour le
moyen-orient sûr